[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now as virtual
schools
continues parents are searching for good
physical outlets for their kids
well there's a local indoor sensory
playground that helps them learn
play and dance let's head to wally
wombats
hi i'm atien carrera from alchemy
breaking academy and i'm his brother
guillaume carrera from alchemy birkin
alchemy breaking is a dance program here
in las vegas
we run out of multiple locations all
around the valley
and we teach kids and adults how to
break
[Music]
we're actually on location at one of our
locations
wally wombats we teach here twice a week
we teach tuesdays and thursdays from 6
15 to 7 45 we also do
a show um a pre-show before
the actual classes and people that are
here at wally wombats
can try a free intro class that's about
20 minutes long
a lot of the principles that we learn
from dance
translates into life skills it helps
build self-confidence
it improves your social skills and it
helps set goals and
knowing what it takes to achieve these
goals as well as the physical attributes
which is um improves your flexibility
your range of motion
stamina strength hand sand walks as many
as you got
yes nice i think it's really important
especially in today's day and age with
uh you know what the world is going
through
kids need an outlet they can't just be
cooped up in their homes in front of a
tv screen
for hours on end they have all this pent
up energy and
they need to get it out and getting it
out in a healthy way
is super important for mental health and
physical health
it's definitely something close to our
heart dance has done
a lot for myself and my brother
just in our life and i think it's a
perfect time to give back
and i think it's about passing down
the knowledge we acquired along the way
just to build up the new generation
[Music]
[Music]
so like my brother said they can come in
and try a free class
um and if they're interested
in signing up with our program they
would just talk to one of the
instructors and we would get them set up
we have three locations across the vegas
valley
here at wally wombats we have one on
saharan decatur
and then we have one on 215 and tanaya
wale wombats is located on north rainbow
boulevard for more information call 702
463